toutes ces scènes aussi dans le château
vous relooker petit à petit d'ailleurs
j'ai plein de projets à voir avec vous
on veut en profiter
il n'y travaille plus depuis deux ans
mais christophe leray n'a pas rompu ses
liens avec le château de breteuil dans
sa scénographie il avait énormément
d'imagination de bord il savait
construire une scène à partir de rien
ici oui et vous c'était un endroit
complètement perdu une ancienne céleri
en ruine et cetera il est arrivé à en
faire quelque chose de merveilleux
l'un des travaux les plus marquants de
christophe la mise en scène des contes
de perrault
celui ci représente près de cinq mois de
travail et plonge le public dans
l'histoire de cendrillon
c'est une vraie création née dans un
ancien local technique et et tout a été
créé de a à z dans cet espace ici il y
avait des tracteurs avant il y à 7 ans
christophe débute un stage au château
il est chargé du développement culturel
c'est là que j'ai compris en fait que
c'était véritablement la muséographie
plus qu'un goût c'était une véritable
vocation de mener des projets de diriger
des équipes d'aboutir un résultat
d'avoir un d'établir un concept et puis
de le concrétiser un travail appris en
autodidacte mais cette passion lui vient
du théâtre un art qu'il pratique avec
une troupe saint-quentinoise
elle a commencée il ya 17 ans un âge de
13 ans je cherchais à avoir une activité
artistique beaucoup moins solitaire
puisque je faisais de la peinture depuis
l'âge de 6 ans mais c'est un travail
d'atelier j'ai intégré un conservatoire
à coignières dirigée par monique fonds
didion et au bout de trois mois il m'a
proposé un rôle dans sa troupe d'adultes
la troupe du crâne que j'ai intégré et
ce qui faisait que cette première année
à l'âge de mes 13 ans je faisais 8
heures de théâtre par semaine et sauf
c'est un être particulièrement adorable
gentils tous vos étés à tout amour toute
intégrité et j'avoue que j'apprécie ça
ces démarches envers moi et sa
promptitude et les apparemment très
équilibré c'est un homme de main
également qu'il sait faire les décors
qui qu'il bricole beaucoup qu'il a le
sens de la scène et le respect dû mettre
17 ans plus tard christophe joue
toujours avec la troupe du crâne
il en est même devenu le président et
travaille à multiplier leurs
partenariats leur nouvelle résidence le
théâtre du château de brousse est
inaugurée en 1957 par la comédie
française